so there's this movie that just came out
called Wonder Park in January 2018 the
director of Wonder Park was fired for
allegedly sexually harassing co-workers
and rather than just hire a competent
director or even another director to
replace him the producers opted to just
not do that now for for animated film
this isn't super strange I mean it's
it's a little strange but it isn't
incomprehensible animated movies are
basically made in slow motion so it's
it's entirely possible for a movie to be
basically at a point where the movie is
kind of done long before it's actually
finished like the movies being
storyboarded and the animatics are done
and all the voice work is done and
there's even basically a rough edit of
the film and now it's just in the slow
grueling process of actually finishing
it at that point the creative leads can
pretty much just be left to their own
devices to figure it out themselves
they're probably all you know competent
creative individuals who are capable of
like solving problems and making
decisions and reaching a consensus and
if they do hit any sort of creative
impassable roadblock where some
executive decision needs to be made well
you know the producers are still there
and that is literally the producers job
so you get to the end of action park and
there's no director credit like it's not
left blank it's just it's not there at
all it is entirely absent that said it's
super obvious that Wonder Park is a
movie with no credited director because
the big thing it lacks is direction it
is in a word in substantial if you took
my neighbor totoro and inside out and
the prologue of up and you just took
those
movies and you stuck him in a blender
and you liquefied them and then you took
that and dumped it into a swimming pool
and then you took an eyedropper of the
pool water that would be this movie this
movie is the homeopathic version of
inside-out now before going into it I
heard that this movie was gonna be like
right up my alley that it was yet
another movie that attempts to mix
childish whimsy with grim heavy story
and and boy was I disappointed I
actually watched him monster calls a few
hours earlier in preparation just to
like calibrate my my internal
instruments and it turned out it wasn't
needed because there is nothing there a
monster calls if you're not familiar
with it is a 2016 drama about a boy who
retreats into fantasy to try and cope
with his mother's terminal cancer it's
it's a beautiful film and it's
gut-wrenching it's a really complex and
nuanced story about confronting death
and the way that stories and fantasies
can be a distraction from facing reality
but they can also be a huge aid in
helping us process difficult emotions in
helping us rationalize complicated
things like grief and anger and guilt
fantasy films about kids dealing with
sick or dying parents is actually a
whole sub-genre unto itself for your
older teens and adults you've got I kill
joints for your tweens and up you've got
a monster calls and for all ages there's
my neighbor totoro
wonder Park is technically the same
genre but only technically there is a
mom who gets sick and needs to go away
so she does and then she's back at the
end and the rest of the movie just kind
of happens in between those two points
like there's a lot of disconnected prom
here so let's make a list 1 the setup is
overly complicated so the setup is that
this young girl Jun and her mom create
Wonderland as a collaborative bedtime
story with Jun stuffed animals filling
the role of mascot staff and hosts her
stuffed monkey peanut is the Mickey
Mouse type ringleader who magics the
rides into existence and yes I said
Wonderland the park in wonder park is
called Wonderland and they repeat this
over and over
you are the Wonder in Wonderland in the
interior fiction of Wonderland peanut is
the creator who manifests Wonderland via
ideas that he receives whispered on the
wind when Jun's mom whispers Jun's ideas
into the stuffed animal peanuts ear look
I know it's a lot of steps but they
spend a lot of time in the movie itself
negotiating the process because after
mom gets sick and goes away it's the
fact that Jun doesn't feel right
whispering ideas into peanuts ear that's
the thing that causes her to abandon
Wonderland backing up a bit before Jun's
mom gets sick Jun actually builds a
makeshift roller coaster in the backyard
out of fencing and a wagon and the the
ensuing chaos ends up demolishing a
bunch of the neighborhood and almost
gets Jun killed so after that Jun and
her mother start building Wonderland as
clockwork miniatures that this this
sprawling clockwork miniature that ends
up taking over most of the house
so then June's mom gets sick and has to
go away for treatment and Jun packs up a
Wonderland and becomes overly protective
of her dad and his health and at this
point the movie still isn't done setting
up because dad then sends Jun off to
math camp but on her way there she
like has a panic attack she she imagines
this scenario where her dad is going to
like eat pizza and drink beer all summer
and get fat and lazy and if he doesn't
have a heart attack he's going to light
the house on fire or explode or
something so she imagines this elaborate
scenario and convinces herself that she
needs to go home and so she creates a
catastrophe on the bus forcing the bus
to stop and giving her an opportunity to
sneak away and and take the hiking
trails back home then finally as she's
walking through the forest she comes
across the magical abandoned ruins of
Wonderland and the movie properly starts
so Wonderland as she finds it is in
disrepair because she stopped imagining
it so she needs to rekindle her
imagination and fix the park to save it
from the darkness all right issue two
the character designs are boring so the
fantasy Wonderland is staffed with
magical talking versions of June's
stuffed animals but these characters are
really unmemorable in their designs both
in terms of being characters in a
Nickelodeon film that will no doubt lean
heavily on merchandising and also in
terms of being the mascots of a
fictional theme park the only one that
has any Flair is boomer the bear who is
blue and that's it he's still otherwise
just a bear but he's blue otherwise
they're all just generic cartoon animals
three the camera work is chaos the three
things that this movie really loves are
extreme high angles extreme wide-angle
lenses that are super close-up and
completely unmotivated movement that
just spins everywhere it's the kind of
shot that animators like to block
because it's complicated and it gives
them a chance to show off but then it
happens so often and it's so repetitive
that it starts to feel like showing
like it happens often enough that it's
calling attention to itself and it
starts to feel almost like the director
was fired and then the animators were
just left to their own devices without
direction for a year for the main
conflict isn't really the main conflict
it's actually really unfair to compare
this movie to something like a monster
calls because it's not really about June
dealing with her mother's illness June's
mother's illness isn't the thing that
the movie is about it's just the thing
that happens after the start of the
movie but before the rest of the movie
the conflict in Wonderland doesn't
really have anything to do with it or
how June is handling it really the story
is a post-apocalyptic action-adventure
zombie movie in a decrepit theme park
then tacked on to that you have a token
ill-defined generic sort of don't let
the spark of creativity die type message
to kinda tie it all together so
Wonderland is being devoured by the
darkness a storm cloud vortex hovering
over the park that has infected the
parks signature toys turning them into
an army of chimpanzees that are
demolishing the park and taking the
wreckage and and hurling it up into the
vortex of the darkness Jun defeats the
darkness when she finds the personal
will to whisper ideas into Peanuts ear
allowing him to then manifest them into
the world of Wonderland and they use
that to then turn on the park again so
that they can just reset everything but
then there's still a small remnant of
the darkness hanging over the park of
all the movies Wonder Park wants to be
it wants most of all to be inside out so
that's why you have this weak
nod to the idea that being sad isn't
always a bad thing five this is just the
setup for the TV show that's the reason
any of this exists and it's also the
reason it exists the way that it exists
the movie doesn't really matter it's
just laying the foundation for the
Nickelodeon series that is already in
production and that's why the setup is
so complicated and also so insubstantial
they're just they're just seeding ideas
that they can come back to in the TV
show it's also probably why the
characters are so bland the animals are
really simple and basic specifically so
that the models will play nice in a
simplified television rendering pipeline
it's also why June doesn't really need
to deal with any meaningful character
growth beyond establishing the
perpetuity of Wonderland is why they
didn't bother replacing the director it
doesn't matter
the movie was always just the precursor
to the TV show so it doesn't need to be
good or coherent it just needs to exist
even the cloud of darkness lingering in
Wonderland at the end feels less like a
meaningful resolution and more like a
plot seed like all right here's our
antagonists generator that show writers
can use whenever they need to explain
why something in Wonderland is broken or
misbehaving funny enough this is
actually kind of the opposite of those
movies like where a monster calls and I
kill Giants and to really the sort of
magical realism of my neighbor totoro
are are about people retreating into
fantasy in order to deal with or cope
with or rationalize something in their
life but in wonder Park June doesn't
retreat into fantasy to deal with her
mother's illness it's the opposite she
rejects fantasy and becomes too
practical
and needs to rediscover imagination but
she doesn't need to rediscover
imagination to cope with her mother's
illness it's she just needs to
rediscover imagination because her
sadness is eating the park for the
purpose of the film it doesn't really
matter why June is sad and the validity
of that is never explored like mom's
illness could have been replaced with
anything it doesn't matter that she's
sick we don't address the fact that
she's sick and how June relates to that
how she processes it all that matters is
that there is an interruption of some
kind so the validity of June's sadness
it's just it's not it's not brought up
at all in fact it's so not relevant that
the animals blame June for wrecking the
park because she created the darkness
and the movie is just like yeah you know
what it is kind of her fault for getting
sad she should have thought about how
her sadness would make other people feel
which I don't know about you but that's
a great message for children